second of three tonight against the
pirates senior ram truck starter for the
diamondbacks the right-hander taylor
whitener
back from the reno roster to bank this
start only his seventh all year
spanked past the first baseman walker
so the batting race continues frazier
entered the game with an average of 3 28
2-2 to hayes freezer holding it first
swaying gonna miss on a fastball up and
in
and taylor wieder gets his first track
3-2 to gamble frazier on the move
swinging and a miss went back to that
change-up and got his second strikeout
diamondbacks and the pirates d-bags
coming up
the civilian lottery will bring you
tyler anderson's numbers
not too shabby
it definitely has been our most solid
pitcher
i miss the old days where the next pitch
could be a foot outside the strike three
guy hit 212 is going to argue
you know what i mean yeah i hear you
off the injured list he just dialed in
real good
here's a pretty slider right there and
he gets already his third strikeout
through five batteries
he's the fastball out there six in a row
set down by widener he's punched down
four no score d-backs and the pirates
here's the one-two pitch and a swing and
a miss
oh foul tip instead he struck him out
and so one out i think that was a
change-up i think he said that was an 84
fastball on the scoreboard
that's not true yeah that was not it
yeah two outs for josh reddick the lefty
batter gets to start against the lefty
pitcher
and he swings and sends one tailing away
from reynolds center long run and he
dives and makes the catch ryan reynolds
another five-star catch that all-star
does it with the bat
and with the glove what an amazing jump
he got on that ball and that was full
extension can't say enough about that
you see a lot of guys going after balls
but man that was really special
and now perez lines one to right field
michael perez
will have extra bases to start
[Applause]
this top of the third a double
[Applause]
foul tip zaha
says he hung on and that's the strike
so there's a big out for taylor widener
twang and a miss there's the slider
chase
six strikeouts for taylor widener two
down in the third one and two now
let's see when jimbo taylor widener
three consecutive strikeouts he's got
seven punch outs through three
[Applause]
good work
strikes him out
it's number
four brings up
taylor widener no two pitch strike three
call went down on the way with the
fastball struck him out
so
tyler anderson five strikeouts through
three perfect innings matched his career
high right there through three innings
seven strikeouts three consecutive with
first and third and nobody out to
taylor widener there it is that's four
consecutive strikeouts and a new career
high
eight strikeouts through three in the
third winder already with a career-high
eight strikeouts tonight hasn't pitched
very much in the major leagues but
here's the pitch and the swing of the
ball blasted out to right
watch this thing go
deep to right and gone for gregory
polanco
his tenth home run of the year and the
pirates have some runs for anderson it's
two nothing it's a beautiful thing to
watch him put his swing in motion when
it's hot and he's been swinging a pretty
good badass of late and right there
getting that pitch and really turn it on
that was the one mistake wideners make
one on one out and there is escobar now
here's when you want to keep everything
rolling
down the line that's a fair ball rojas
on the move
he's coming around third they're going
to send him here's the throw it's up the
line diamondbacks on the board head
edwardo escobar
line drive base into the center
you like that one bob oh yeah
101.6 miles an hour off the bat
and that could be two one
no
so the pirates get a run get that run
back that rbi by gamble makes it three
to one nagowski drew the one out walk in
the fourth
and a line did it the left field did he
is this his first
he clears the deck with a cannonball the
big nagowski's first
there she is
the power of no-go
gonzo
he is something else
he is something else he's feeling so
good right now
here's the set in the 1-2 pitch and
swinging a miss struck him out six
strikeouts for anderson tonight nick is
batting lead off for a reason good
numbers against anderson good numbers
against left-handers but so far he's
over two
broken back just beyond the reach of
nagowski renek is home rbi for ahmed and
it's 5-2
getting in a little bit of a dangerous
territory here aren't we loaded yeah
tying runs at first base yeah quick
happens quick sometimes huh so we're
going to come back to the mound they can
go to the plate get one perez to first
two a double play great job right there
it's as easy as one two three
walker slams it to left
and that gets to the wall escobar is on
the run
they're gonna stop him at third he's
gonna run through the sign no throw
diamondbacks have a run it's five to
three
tony paris chica said uh-oh and escobar
was not stopping it's the rbi double for
walker
and meter sends one to right center and
var shows on the run
sultan varshall that gets to the wall he
will score josh van nader is in at third
harry has got the rbi triple
now they've scored now in four
consecutive innings
and it's a one-run ball game and now the
diamondbacks who trailed in the fifth
inning five to one have the towing one
at third with nobody out in the seventh
ahmed trying to dunk it into right and
we're tied at five
nick ahmed second rbi tonight two runs
across for arizona they've tied it at
five in the seventh pitch blasted out to
left
deep camel to the wall and makes the
catch leaping with two hands
and the runners have to stay put what a
great catch by ben gamel and left can't
say enough about that catch right there
an ability to stay on his feet more
importantly and get the ball back into
the infield he hit that wall
literally it's 5-5 d-backs and the
pirates
reddick sends one to left-center and
here we go
ahmed scores rojas is home walker stops
at third diamondbacks have the lead they
now lead at 7-5
to short oh it eats them up
christian is home rennick hustles into
third and it's eight to five one two one
marshall
all right shopper
kind of in between there
marshall beats it up and reddick scores
it's nine to five
here's that dalton varsity speed and
it's a six run seventh
and mater drives it deep to center
reynolds backing up they won't get it
here comes marshall van meter
is three for three
they trailed it five to one they lead it
11-5.
center field josh redick is there
diamondbacks have the win
they've won three in a row and they
clinch a series win they can go for the
sweep with mad bomb on the mound
tomorrow afternoon